We have a voicemail number, which you can
call anytime that the mood strikes.
That number is two one nine two.
David P..
Here's a caller asking.
OK, OK, OK.
Maybe Trump is not likely to delay the election,
but if he does, who becomes president?
A good question.
Take a listen.
David, hi.
I just wanted to call and give you a little
bit of a correction on something you said
last week when you're talking about Trump's
obscene tweet about delaying the election.
You said that if the situation were that we
didn't have an election by January 20th, that
Nancy Pelosi would become the of United States
because Trump's term would expire.
Obviously, Mike Pence's term would expire.
The first part is right.
Their terms expire, but.
The second part is not actually Nancy Pelosi
will also be on the ballot and her term expires
a little earlier in January if there's no
election.
So she the entire House would basically be
empty if there were no election.
And so Nancy Pelosi would actually not be
the president that states the president, that
states would be who's third in line, which
would be the president pro tem of the Senate,
86 year old and actually 87.
By that time, Chuck Grassley.
So that will be Chuck Grassley, president.
An entire house that is completely vacant
and a Senate that is a third vacant base.
So there's actually it's actually even more
complicated than this.
So first of all, it is conceivable.
Imagine that.
So the election is really 50 elections, right?
Each state runs an election.
It doesn't appear as though Trump can just
delay the election from the federal level.
But he could ask governors to delay state
elections.
It could happen that enough state elections
are delayed such that there is no winner in
the presidential race.
But California might have their election.
And Nancy Pelosi could win.
So it's actually, from what I'm reading, conceivable
that you might not have enough states running
elections to have anybody get to 270 electoral
votes.
But if California did their election, it's
theoretically possible that Nancy Pelosi would
be elected to another term.
But let's actually play.
Let's imagine that the House is vacant.
Okay.
It would not be Chuck Grassley.
What would happen?
From my understanding and I went over it with
producer Pat today, a couple of times there
are a bunch of senators who are up for reelection.
And it's true, it's one third of the Senate.
They would all those 35 seats would all be
vacant.
So you would have 65 senators left because
Republicans have way more seats to defend
right now than Democrats.
The 35 seats that would be open would be mostly
Republican seats.
This would put the Senate back in Democratic
control, at which point they would vote on
who becomes Senate pro tem.
And usually they go with the most senior senator.
Which would be Vermont Senator Patrick Leahy.
So so it's actually even more complicated
if the election were delayed and nobody.
There were no no elections at all.
The Senate elections don't happen.
That leaves 35 Senate seats vacant.
The House is vacant.
OK, the remaining 65 senators who are more
Democrats than Republicans vote on a new Senate
pro tem, one who becomes president by history.
That would be Patrick Leahy knowing that the
person would become president.
Maybe they would vote for someone who's younger
than Patrick Leahy.
I don't know.
But it's like two layers more complicated
even than that.
And hopefully it doesn't come to this.
I don't believe that it will.
I believe we will have a presidential election.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the new Republican
backed Heal's act.
We'll talk about what's going on in the NBA.
We will talk about Canadians sneaking I'm
sorry, Americans sneaking into Canada in boats.
Yes, we are now the ones doing that.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show